[Music]
hey everyone
how's it going welcome back to the
channel
today's episode is an interview with
someone i
admire and respect very much as an
architect and
as a person if i had to use one word to
describe him
it would be generous he is
generous in his work in his practice and
is
just an incredibly generous and
wonderful person
scott kemp is a sole practitioner who's
been working with indigenous communities
for the past 15 years
and before that he's worked with
architects like
shin takamatsu and bing tom and
before he started his own practice he
was a partner at omicron
but he decided to follow his passion
when he started working with first
nations communities
i thought it would be interesting to
hear from him
because right now i feel like a lot of
us are
learning and re-learning how to
engage with our communities especially
the ones who's been marginalized
throughout history
and as you know the indigenous people of
canada have been chronically mistreated
throughout history
and so we will take a look at how
he helps to create positive change in
these communities through
some of his projects scott also
sits on a lot of local and national
committees
including the cala the canadian
architectural licensing authorities
and the aibc the architectural
institution of canada
and the afbc the architectural
foundation of canada
and he was also the past president of
the aibc
right now it seems that there is a push
for
change in the profession and so i wanted
to hear
his thoughts on our roles as architects
as well as
his thoughts on the future of the
profession uh
that being said this was my first
interview on
zoom so there were a few technical
hiccups
and i did let the interview run a little
bit long so i have divided the interview
into two parts
although the themes blend into each
other
in the first interview we will talk
about his work and his approach to
working with indigenous communities
and in the second video we will take a
step back
and look at the profession in general
i understand you don't have a website am
i right i know i'm terrible
i'm really bad you know and i have all
the material and i have somebody that
could do it i just never bothered
to get it done so how do you get
commissions
it's just referrals yeah and i
and i don't answer rfps i don't do any
rfps
oh really i'm not really set up for that
like
again i'm a sole practitioner so the
kind of
marketing effort required to answer rfps
i don't do
and so far i got more work than i know
what to do with
so i haven't it hasn't been a problem
and it's not not necessarily
how one should do it from the business
point of view
um but so far it's been successful for
me so
like i just keep getting work i got
another job yesterday
so it just keeps coming
i mean i guess that means your clients
are fairly happy with your work well
one of the things that's very nice like
the the indigenous communities
um well there's many but they're also
they do
have a fair amount of contact between
them yeah they're pretty close-knit
community
yeah so that's really good and they're
very loyal they're fantastic clients
like i read
the work that i do and how did you get
your first commission
uh the very first commission was
actually
in uh for who patches that first nation
it was a carving shed
right yeah that's the design build one
right yeah
oh okay cool so they the herpetra set
they didn't do totem poles like most
totem poles tell stories
yeah all the figures uh are
storytelling that's in the poll
what the chat do is welcoming figures
and they are actual
figures um they carve two a male and a
female
straight in the middle of town wanted to
they haven't done one in 100 years so
they wanted to carve
two welcoming figures so the man
welcoming people from the land
female welcoming people from the water
and they wanted to carve the poles on
the site so we built a little carving
shed
so that the workers had cover when they
were carving
yeah that was a beautiful little
structure it was fun
i went and built it yeah so i built it
with
two with three community members so did
they already have construction skills
so you taught them how to build yeah
they were the three guys were
very handy but i was kind of the site
superintendent site foreman
you seem to do that a bit there's also
in the portfolio was the buddhist temple
so a friend of mine is in that community
or involved in the buddhist
community and it's in coombs on
vancouver
so he approached me and wanted we worked
on other projects together
he approached me and wanted me to do
this design
you know to house the guru rinpoche
and he told me the story so they
how many they had 20 so this is the
tibetan community
there's 25 of guru rinpoche's all around
the world
and when you see guru rinpoche he
gives you guidance and good feeling
sends off good vibes
he placed them all around the world so
the world is wrapped up in goodness from
guru rinpoche which is kind of an
actuary
anyways this community got chosen for
one of them which is quite
so well yeah so he asked me to do the
design i did the design and then
afterwards he said oh and we're not we
don't have any general contractors when
they build it ourselves you have to come
and show us how to build it
each weekend most weekends for about a
year and a half
with the community cool okay what are
the benefits of being your own
contractor
i i enjoyed it i've always that again to
me
i love the whole process of architecture
concept right through to you know finish
building
some steps that i enjoy so building is
one of them
and i've always enjoyed kind of hands-on
instruction but you're a sole proprietor
right
so that must be quite a bit of work for
one person well
it gives you the the freedom to do that
if you want
that's that's kind of why i've set the
firm up the way it is
like it is just me and and people that
work on contract with me
or collaborate together gives me the
freedom
to do what i want like if i have 20
people
um like to be honest you're not doing
architecture
you become the marketer and the manager
yeah
not doing architecture i love doing
architecture so that's why i've kept the
firm very small so if i want to
go away for a week or two weeks or three
weeks and work on site
that's fine um yeah people to
staff for other partners i can go do
that if i want so are you also
learning quite a bit about their local
traditional construction techniques
yes both back and forth um
but also even more importantly is the
design
it's the actual design of the building
can you give us an example the way we
when we we go into these communities in
the indigenous communities
um i don't i don't design it
really they design it so i go in with
the roll of sketch paper and pens
and i just listen and they
they talk and through that process
we come up with the design i'll show you
okay
so um
so there's a typical design shred
so i don't really say anything
i just listen and i draw
and then at the end of it if we get
we get that you know can take two three
four hours
we start at one end of the sketch paper
and go to the other end
through that consultation through that
listening
because it's their building it's not my
building
i think that's where
you know the more i become the more i do
architecture like you train to kind of
it's
it's your building yeah exactly
i'm less supportive of that position
now right i think that's community's
building right yeah so is this
process pretty similar throughout um a
lot of your project
yeah we do we do all the time yep
so sketching skill is pretty important
well it's fun i enjoy it
here's another example so this is
uh sacom which is on vancouver island
near swartz bay
they wanted uh daycare
um and when we met with them i've got a
couple of sketches but
it's not the whole role it's just a
couple of them but they talked about
wanting like a long house they wanted to
talk about a traditional form
but almost like a village so there's a
series of long houses all connected
together
mm-hmm that so as they were talking
drew yeah that was the form
that was the kind of concept
and that became the building so then
another one was
um so this is saiku so this is up near
vanderhoff near prince george
uh also daycare and
uh the team that we're meeting with
was quite specific about
the program of the building like they
wanted one r
or one side of they sit at one side of
the corridor initially
where you have the daycare which is
infant toddlers and the three to five
and the nap room and
storage and toilets yeah the other side
they wanted
a cultural room and after school care
but then she started talking about uh
playground needs to be somewhat central
and part of
so everybody has access needs to be
protected
and then she's um we
wrap our hands around the children and
she did this
where the design came in so from that we
sketched that
so there's the building there's the
hands wrapping around
playground oh i love that that's the
entrance so all of this is done
this is all done live i don't touch
these drawings afterwards i'm drawing
these
while we're meeting right and then
and then that's there's the building so
you really are just
listening and sketching and they're
designing they're part of it
again especially with indigenous
communities they're
visual they're yeah they're they have
huge
skills graphically and visually
you know um but also
historically everything has been done
for them
they're kind of wards of the state
exactly
canada set it up um
and normally when a building is built in
indigenous community
it's funded by the federal government
the federal government hires all the
consultants
and consultants do the work they
have some consultation i don't know what
extent
yeah they then tender it a contractor
comes in
and builds it and that the end of that
uh they're given the keys to the
building
so they're not really involved so what
we try to do is
the exact opposite so we go in
with a blank piece of paper
and we work with them to to design the
building
but also the one of the major focuses of
all our projects
is to try to maximize
the returns of the potentials of the
project
so we really focus on building capacity
within the community so that means
training
employment everything using materials
using
local craftsmen like for instance what
do i got here
um i've done quite a few i've done three
projects with mala hat first nations
they're on the island
they're very progressive they're great
community
they've over the last four or five years
worked really hard
in doing this and creating opportunities
within their community
on from ninety percent unemployment
to ninety percent employment wow
these projects wow one of the projects
we did was
um we renovated their big house
so this is the traditional big house
yeah
and they had a kind of a little building
attached to it
which was the toilet and kitchen
but it was in really bad shape so we
demolished it and then we built this new
addition to it
so all the wood everything is their
trees
they bought a sawmill and all of this
was
milled was cut off their land not
baited on site
by them so is wood the default material
then
just because it's something that the
community can work with
yeah um the use of wood was
the historic uh material
yeah but also like it's a fantastic
material
yeah it only makes sense to use it
and it's also part of the capacity
building so
a lot of these communities are very
remote
like honeycutting you drive to williams
lake
and then you took a three-hour drive
two hours on a gravel road like a really
rough gravel road
so effectively you drive all the way
into williams lake
and then you drive west back again to
the coastal mountains so when you get to
hanikatin
you're basically back at the coast if
you go up and over the mountains
coast so it's very very remote
so to bring stuff into the community is
hugely expensive
you can use trees
uh everything that's there um like we do
we've done a lot of work up and down the
coast again a lot of communities have no
road access it's only water access right
to bring material in too expensive
to bring workers in because you have to
provide them accommodation
and food uh massively expensive
if you hire a local community member
not only do you give them a job you give
them training
yeah we'll save a lot of money so it's
not just the building that's benefiting
the community it's actually the
building of the building yeah because we
went in
bob and i went into and kelly i'll talk
about kelly
um we went into um
a house it which is north of tofino
and again it's only water access they
were building
six plex we went in with right to read
to do
an adult learning center come up with a
concept
at that time they were also building six
plex
residential building and it was a
typical federal government
project right so they came in they got
the funds they came in
the design was already done they hired a
contractor and they're building it
when we were there they were painting so
a
painting company they had five staff
they barged two vehicles in
um so they were staying
the community has a little communal
building where you have accommodation
and then one of
the community members is a book right so
it's very nice
but that crew
was at huge expanse
painting the building no community
members
worked on that building whatsoever oh
interesting
when we were meeting with them they said
this is what we don't want
this is crazy no employment
for community members there's no input
into the design
entity there's no training and long-term
benefit
so that's why we focus all our projects
towards capacity building
and i mentioned kelly i don't know if
you
so i've worked with kelly for a few
years now she was an intern so she's
calton first nations she's from
telegraph greek
um i met her through the
aibc and she
grew up up north but graduated from ubc
was an intern and then really struggled
trying to find employment to finish her
intern hours so i was her mentor
but she wasn't logging any hours so then
we switched it so that i became a
lawyer a colleague of mine gord
became her mentor so then done
projects with me right to read projects
and now she's fully registered oh wow
that she's the fourth
indigenous architect in bc that i know
oh my god
and i think the 70 or 18
in canada wow
yeah there's it's a very small community
yeah yeah so that's part of what we also
do like building capacity from a design
point of view
help kelly get registered
do you find that the way that she
interacts with the community is
quite different from the way that you do
it's great
to be honest i like it when kelly is
there
you know i'm you go into the community
you're still another white guy right
you can't get around that and they've
had lots of
foreigners in the community yeah
be nice having kelly come in
it shows that we are
you know wanting to truly
collaborate and build capacity within
the community
in every regard yeah one of the other
projects i'm working on is
the silica team silicate
national government um they're quite
unique
with first nations in canada
um there's six communities that make up
the silpateen
they're the ones that actually took
the federal government to court and won
a ruling in the supreme court
and actually granted title land
because first nations the federal
government has
given them reserves right
um but and sometimes the reserves really
are not reflective of where their
traditional lands were
and the reserves are a very small
portion of what
they used to use as
you know part of their culture
um so that ruling by the supreme court
actually recognized
it was honeycutting they recognized
their traditional territory and granted
them title
so it's hugely significant legally
within
the world of indigenous communities in
canada
anyway so the silica teen um
they're the six communities have come
together to create
a nation a zucchini nation
they have a government so-called
national government um
they were quite heavily impacted in the
fires of
2017. yeah that was a bad one so this is
the silcatin is near williams lake so
that summer was terrible in that whole
area
they were heavily impacted and
had a lot of unpleasant experiences
through the fires
you know the provincial government is
responsible for fighting fires
um so
the things that happened were like the
the communities would volunteer
knowledge and advice on how to fight the
fires
the eventual firefighters basically
ignored them
jeez yeah um
the at some at some times
you know they they
decided an evacuation was necessary the
provincial government so they
ordered the communities to evacuate
the community said you don't have
authority of us you cannot order us to
evacuate
it's up to them to decide so there's a
lot of
conflict there
and it got to the degree where at one
point
the rcmp said to one community if you
don't evacuate we're going to take the
children
away from you and evacuate them so
given the history my god schools in
canada that was received
rather badly yeah yeah i can imagine
they uh the same thing is like the
each of the community members like they
know the land they know their community
they
and they know you know the cultural
with the cultural knowledge they know
how to fight fires and
was not used not utilized that knowledge
for instance in a lot of communities
they said
you know here's the fire starting if we
do this this and this
um you know we have a chance of
containing it
and five six seven days later they got
around to doing it
by that time was too late so the damage
that occurred
was far greater than if they had been
listened to
the long short of it is they've actually
signed
a memorandum of understanding so the
circuiting
provincial government the federal
government such that
in the event of an emergency like spires
the silca teen now have the authority
to look after their communities this
feasibility study
comes from that request or that
that recognition so what they want to do
is
build evacuation centers for each of the
communities and then a training center
so a lot of the community members know
kind of naturally how to fight forest
fires but they're not formally trained
it would be good for them to be actually
certified as
as uh qualified forest fires right
and also get the equipment and and the
other
uh training that's needed to do this
because they could also do not only
forest fires they could do
like high rescue they could do rapid
water rescue
so anyways they are recognized as being
um
the authority to do this six nations so
i met with each of the six
nations and the reason i'm doing this it
shows you
here's the sketches so this is with
anaheims they talked about
this is evacuation center like the big
house
they wanted again it's you know kind of
a series of villages
so these were just sketches that i did
as they were talking
you know and this is the training center
so they wanted a large room they needed
equipment for uh like equipment bays
for trucks so like we just kind of went
through
they talked about um uh
you know outdoor uh access to water
we wanted places for rvs camping
from those sketches i then did uh
you know just concept plans so that's
the site plan
so that this building is the
evacuation center so that's where the
community will be evacuated to
this training center
so there's the evacuation center
so it's sorry this is the training
center
so it's it's got a large gym it's got
the equipment bays
it's got classrooms it's got cultural
rooms it's got
accommodation for 20 people upstairs
yeah
this is the uh evacuation center so it's
a big house
traditional big house with kitchens and
then a large hall where people can
sleep gather yeah emergencies
so we did that through each of the
communities so this is estee lauder
they talked more about the outdoors they
wanted
um places for other equipment stores but
they wanted
uh places the arbors or a cultural
gathering places they need helicopters
so like as they're talking i'm just
drawing so there's another evacuation
center
and they talked about their kind of logo
as a bird
yeah well can you make the building in
the shape of our local the bird so then
that's where that bank
oh cool uh and then this one
was this guy he was great the chief this
is chief
um russ he says i don't like rectangular
buildings i like her
because they they did like the pit
houses so can we do a curved house like
a pit house
yeah right so then we started doing
these sort of buildings so it's kind of
a half
buried building with quiet rooms
and then big open spaces do you see
and then there's the building so you've
got the big hall
you've got other uh activities and then
all the kind of back of house stuff
is buried into the hill
uh are these all within one session
no these were we had a couple of times
we did
two in one day but i did a couple of
trips going up
two to three to four hours to do yeah
just listening and drawing
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it takes a bit of
time
like twosie talked about you know they
talked about
you know they needed an ambulance center
um
they talked about like sweat lodges
they talked about again by the water
they wanted
tent and rv sites
they they needed they actually said
we need a tower to dry the hoses so that
came
so then that became so this became the
training
training center or the evacuation center
so you could
gain open spaces and then towers
and they actually wanted accommodation
so there's some
um so not this one this is
they wanted a little health center so
this is the health center
there's a hall there's the equipment
base yeah
this community uh
inside adele santa del is actually quite
remote so they again they talked about
um having uh
hide so right you know racks to dry the
hides
um sweat lodges again
little health centers they talked about
along the water they would have arbors
they would have playgrounds they would
have
rv sites um but this is the one
um so this is this is kind of
a small version one
and then anika team um
sorry go back a bit
which one did they have this one
sorry uh we this one has actually
accommodation
because estee law is being very remote
they're on one side of the freezer river
and they used to have a ferry
and the ferry got cancelled just like
that
okay it's gone so okay they it really
has isolated the community
when you bring people into the community
you need to provide housing so these
have kind of
self-contained suites
and then the last one was a nicotine
and um he
it was became a combination of the
longhouse versus the pit house
so uh again they need a place to gather
they need a place where the community
can look after the community in an
evacuation
situation so you talked the big house
you talked about
house so it became kind of a long pit
house
so it's buried on the both sides with
the central
space which is the the communal space
and then all the private functions are
down the side
an open end buried on either side and
then that became the building
i love that these traditional typologies
translate so well into um
modern building yeah it's fun
so is there still quite a bit of
distrust
[Music]
within the community against people who
maybe are funding the project or even
against you yes yep there is
if you know the history of how the
indigenous communities have been treated
um to be honest i'm surprised there's
not more mistrust
yeah i'm not surprised but do you find
that you have to pull things out of them
a little bit more
are there things that are left unsaid
at the table um no i find like if you
again the way we work where we just
listen and draw
yeah um like they've never been
involved in it that way they've never
had the opportunity to
give input so they're hugely receptive
so they there's no part of my problem is
keeping up
yeah to draw fast enough yeah when the
ideas are coming right
yeah forget something yeah right
yeah and there's usually an aha moment
one of those kind of
really insightful moments where
it really starts to click like when
colleen is psychos when she said you
know we wrap our
hands around the children to care for
them
it was kind of an aha moment right
now almost always
there's one of those moments in in these
meetings
that becomes the inspiration and even
from a
practical point of view it seems like a
very
efficient way to do the design process
like in my experience we've usually gone
to the client meeting
they tell us what they need all the
requirements
and then we go back to the office and
then we
we do the sketches we start doing the
concept design and then it's like a
back and forth but yeah
i've never really designed right in
front of the client it seems kind of
scary
i just become a visual record of the
conversation
i bring them back every time i bring all
the sketches back
yeah and they go oh yeah yeah i remember
that
yeah yeah historically
we as a profession when we engage
the community actually that means
you know we make the little colored
squares
on the program elements we put them on
the site we shuffle them around
yeah we get the community members to
shuffle them around
yeah that's okay
but it's a very small part
of the design um
and its program relationship
doesn't give you the spirit of the
building
like with the sketches i try very hard
to make
to draw everything so it's planned
section elevations perspective
so you're really trying to
not only work the building out
functionally
program here's all it works it's sitting
on the side
but also what's it feel like what's it
look like
the spirit of the building and that's
important
in my opinion it's their building it
represents their community
it's it it is um part of rebuilding
their community kenny talks about this
quite
passionately um she
strongly believes that architecture and
art
is the way forward in actually healing
the communities and moving the
communities forward using their culture
as an expression of the community and a
celebration of the community
and art and architecture is part of that
so these
become part of the process of
well she doesn't say reconciliation
because there was never
any conciliation to begin with
[Music]
moving forward
[Music]